leading on from my last video where I
talked about the extension of the
narrative side of the game this will be
a quick video about what we are showing
a mess of entertainment a couple of
weeks ago regarding the upcoming
improvements to the game and ingame
activities that we should expect to see
in YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
by now everyone should be aware of the
upcoming gear 2.0 changes that be
working on so just glance over the
subject quickly the devs have
acknowledged that the gear isn't working
quite as well as they'd like it to with
a lot of players struggling to
understand and even the more advanced
requiring spreadsheets to keep track of
what's good on top of this players
aren't feeling rewarded when they
actually do find an upgrade which is a
massive problem for any RPG they've
explained that the gear 2.0 changes will
be far more intuitive deeper and
satisfying all gear is going to be
rebooted and a bunch of new items will
be added to the loop pool items will be
far easier to understand and the stats
being far more streamlined and speaking
from experience it's very easy to check
on the flyer whether you just picked up
a well rolled item they explained to us
how they've attempted to add more
excitement around the gear to help make
more of it actually useful I'm sure all
of you have those talents that you
double using and are constantly
deconstructing them when you see them
well hopefully there should be less of
this it's not to say that everything you
pick up will be useful to the current
build you're running but that it could
be more useful to other types of builds
or classes of which a lot of this is now
pointed towards with the increased focus
on build diversity I've been excited
about this for a long time and miss the
limitless build options of the division
1 you know the ones we had around 1.7
before classified seats took over but
after the atrocious mid builds that
plagued the early years actually think
this is something that's been missing
from the game since launch
however messing up the builds that
people have been working on over the
previous months is not often received
all that well but this is a necessary
evil and ought to apply these changes to
allow players to learn this new system
the maximum agent level is being
increased from level 30 to level 40 this
will allow players a bit of time to
understand the new items before reaching
the in-game loot this one improvement
should dramatically change the feel of
division 2 orangey and built diversity
bringing us back to how it felt in the
division 1 the developers themselves
have said that they want to return to
their roots in year 2 we'll be receiving
some more skills
play around was I don't think I'm alone
with us but the skills in the division -
just really haven't been that fun but
they also don't feel as useful from a
support point of view I imagine a lot of
this will change when the skill power
overhaul is we've completed but
regardless we're seeing the return of a
skill that I personally have been
missing for the last 12 months the
sticky bomb we've got to play around
with us for a bit and it feels damn good
in fact there is another type of sticky
bomb - called firebrand we didn't get to
see this one in action but from the name
alone I'm sure we can come up with some
good ideas the third skill is called
decoy I did have a play with this one
but only because of the way it's
unlocked and from what I understand the
risks are the same in warlords of New
York you're facing off with Aaron keen
as lieutenants each of them have a
unique skill after you defeat them you
unlock these skills in the mission we
were able to play we came across Theo
Parnell who's using the decoy skill
initially I wasn't all that excited for
the decoy I just wanted to play around
with a sticky bomb some more seeing how
far I could fire an enemy objects across
the map but after a few encounters
running solo I can certainly see the
appeal with multiple heavies coming down
on you it can be tricky to get some of
them to expose their weak points but
when using the decoy this needs to be a
lot of threat which more often than not
has him spinning around to fight the
decoy the last skill was called shock
trap this one looked like a type of
seeker mind so I'm not really sure to
expect here though it must be noted that
they were possibly placeholder images so
it wouldn't read into them too much
the only other improvement or addition
that was mentioned at this time was some
changes to the dark zone the idea behind
the dark zone isn't going to be changed
it's supposed to be a lawless theory of
the game where people can do whatever
they want within reason of course they
can farm solar or they can team up with
others that they come across to help
take down the NPCs who control the area
or you could choose to go rogue and hunt
down other players still either loot for
yourself nothing has changed here over
time the Serie of the game has become a
full PvP zone where people join to fight
other players nothing wrong with us this
is how it was designed
but in an attempt to bring the duck zone
back to more of a PvE VP area the
developers have planned a number of
additions that will send Vice more in
the way of friendly interaction we
didn't see any of these additions and
I'm hopeful but certainly very skeptical
personally I missed the early days of
the dark zone and the division one you
didn't know whether they were gonna help
you or shoot at you you had to be on
your toes the APCs were so tough that
you really needed the help but any
moment the other player could change
their mind but these days it's always
guaranteed that they'll shoot at you
so either shooting first or get the hell
out of there having a mix of
interactions and there would be
certainly a nice change but for it to be
worth it you'd need some incentive to
farm there in the first place
currently there is very little heating
in the dark zone that you couldn't just
get somewhere else
I've said it before I'll say it again
I love the fact that the division too
has continued to the story through each
addition to the game the Division one
story was great but nothing really
happened after you ran it through the
first time however and saying that I
certainly would have never hoped for
them to do this in place of adding
replayability to the game which it kind
of feels like they did but they've been
listening and for year two we'll have a
few more activities thrown our way
although we didn't get any hands-on
experience with the universe they
briefly covered what we should be
expected to see firstly we'll be seeing
the return of legendary difficulty
missions I'm stoked about this and the
division one these were the way which
had put a new bill to the test
so it actually lines up quite nicely
with the gear 2.0 release for anyone not
familiar with legendary missions these
are the most challenging difficulty
level to date that can be applied to
certain existing missions sort of like
heroic except much harder these are
intended for only the most well geared
and capable groups and for those after a
true challenge they can be run solo but
it certainly isn't easy something you
have seen or heard of in other games
seasons are being introduced in the
division - these will be new many
campaigns offering extensions to the
narrative that run every three months
participating in season will open up in
Achra wards such as skill mods
gear and cosmetics
global events are making a return these
are shorter events usually running for a
week and contain modifiers that
dramatically change the way that you
play the game this too will work quite
well in conjunction with gear 2.0 we're
having alternative builds depending on
the modifiers as almost a requirement am
unsure of what rewards these were
contained at the stage but they have
said that there'll be something called
leaks that will be added with a more
competitive players can work towards
placings on the leaderboards etc but
more details on this is to become lastly
but not least they are adding a better
past system where players are rewarded
as it progressed through a tier system
similar to what you see in Ghost Recon
breakpoint no information has been given
at this point on how to acquire XP
towards each tier the types of rewards
or the potential monetization options
so there you have it were the last video
took about in the direction the story is
going in and this one talking about the
improvements in in game that will soon
be seeing in warlords of New York the
only thing that I probably haven't shown
too much of is the gameplay so for
anyone interested in seeing more of that
I'll try and get something up over the
next year sir there was only so much we
were able to try out but this should
give you an idea and what are my
thoughts on everything I saw I think
it's heading in the right direction as
I've stated multiple times before I
thoroughly enjoyed a narrative direction
the games taking and take it's an
improvement of its predecessor this
isn't to say that I think that division
2 story is bitter just that the Division
one story stayed the same over three
years what we got on release was it
however the division 2 story is
constantly unfolding I know this may be
a somewhat controversial opinion there's
a lot of people seem to believe that the
Division one story is far superior
however I do think there is a little bit
of nostalgia behind us being that it was
a new IP and I wonder if it would be a
different story
and it all been laid out in front of us
from day one but I guess we won't know
since we haven't seen everything yet I'm
loving what I'm seeing in the gear 2.0
changes and I can't wait to get into
some proper build crafting the addition
of global events seasons and even the
battle paths will give a bunch more
reasons to log in and I think the
diehard fans of the game grind every
single one of them but I don't really
think it's quite enough I'd like to see
some more replayable game-mode sejun
that aren't locked behind dates I'm
certainly not jumping on the bandwagon
of saying survival and underground must
be added I very much enjoyed them
especially survival but we've had that
it's been done I'm saying take what
worked on both of these activities and
make up some new ones for the division 2
before I go there was no mention of any
changes or additions to PvP well though
not a massive division PvP oh I can
think of a significant chunk of the
community that are there may be a little
upset but us however what we need to
remember is that everything will show in
a couple of weeks ago isn't everything
will be getting a year to they'll be
keeping some things to themselves stuff
that they're still working on in the
background but they aren't quite ready
to talk about you
so long story short I think it's a giant
step in the right direction but there
was a little less content than I was
hoping for
regardless much dude I'll be getting all
up in this in a way thanks for watching
hopefully I didn't miss anything but if
you have any questions or need something
clarified just leave a comment or find
me on discord social media spill check
description yeah Cheers
you